[Musique]
et bien bonjour à tous et bienvenue je
veux dire que mario ou mario dans
friends on sait pas alors aujourd'hui on
est sur joe hogan c'est un jeu qui se
joue en coupe
si on simplement de me l'envoyer ils ont
gentiment accepté c'était en gros on va
jouer à perso bleu est un berceau rouge
il avance tout seul face à eux des
femmes vont se trouver des portails bleu
ou rouge
il faut que le perso de nous deux qui
est devant soit celui de la même couleur
que le portail qui arrive moi je vais
prendre le poisson comme ça je suis bien
reconnaissable et toi je prends la chose
c'est le seul qui peut appuyer c'est
celui qui est derrière up pour passer
devant au piège pas dehors switch
nintendo switch faire au nom allégeant
français des gens français s'impose à
lui moins une allumette
[Musique]
mais casteu play on est au niveau 1 au
niveau un mec c'est choquant alors ce
n'est pas le cas c'est moins qu'à puis
avec justement ça donne du stress
notamment majoritairement vachement
switch nom d'allah oui c'est dur le
niveau est située sur ton beau gosse
c'est parce que c'est vraiment style ans
que je viens de faire attends je suis
désolé osama me masser à précieux faudra
que tu as fait quoi tarnec no fake quoi
mais mais qu'attend pas la dernière
seconde
mecha me carle garde voilée l'orma aux
oies mais on a fait un perfect
attachement bâtiment ou d'un fils toute
l affaire permet au bafa d'eclagnens et
l on voit très bien pourquoi je me suis
dit que c'était tout est ok faut que je
sache en switch switcher c'est toi qui
tu es derrière ce tatouage
[Musique]
en fait ce qui est dur c'est qu'elle a
fait perdre on est bien là mais quel
regard la vitesse de croisière voilà tu
vas au c'est moi qui serai qui va devoir
s'acquitter derrière moi je le trouve
excellent qu'elle travaille l'équipe
[Musique]
banon nice à moi à toi à moi alors que
cette annonce est un total équivalent à
notre corps piste qui diminuera mais on
a passé on la passera de 100 à tanger
fès
[Musique]
définition de la viande il faut se
baisser maintenant quand les [ __ ]
parfait parfait à parfaire serendip le
mans tu as fait voeu de tailler dans
leurs calculs les avaient pas pris en
compte que deux mecs peuvent être aussi
osé dire à cet endroit
oh là là [ __ ] dire de la gymnastique
rythmique
je n'ai pas je veux qu'on fasse les
mêmes bases à renouveler ce toi ce tweet
hockey yes inverse
abbas et sa droite ou dernière oui
pardon
ok je te vois pas fait s'ils restent
devant non pas dans les buts un bol a
réussi [ __ ] mais gallas il n'y a
qu'une hâte c'est moi qui ai plein
[Musique]
ona réussite au bac c'est ok on passe à
la vraie difficulté le deuxième je
n'arrive plus à parler alors passons
tout de suite a dit et sans explication
et nouvelle mécanique ou pas c'est quoi
ça c'est des truismes harris tu paries
nom jean luc et moi qui peux y aller ok
d'accord elle avait comme il peut y
aller et je viens de rater au pire et le
pire égoïsme heck
c'est vraiment moi jamais switch
barrière tu vois les tumeurs personnes
nous formate en faisant croire qu'il
faut ok khady fall et switch en fait le
tout c'est de faire confiance à l'autre
ok faut juste pas paniqué j'ai pas nous
qui va on va enfin pourquoi taire ou
switch puis il atteint ressources que
fais tu et à toi de sweet 7 juillet moi
je moi j'ai une étoile et toi non
et ben me casser la fin de cette vidéo
sur jogar nôtre ça s'appelait sais pas
c'était sympa mais aussi postulons assez
facile on retiendra le mot switch en
fait je vais faire je n'en ai craché une
katy perry switch mais en fait c'est pas
la même basse et je me suis aperçu au
doute
abonnez vous n'hésitez pas à amener
dossier vous a plus impatients la chaîne
de mai car c'est toujours toi qu'on
n'avait pas joué un petit vieux comme ça
un mois de pause et ça fait si longtemps
iv mario
[Musique]
non quand même pas mais ça faisait comme
un bon moment ça m'a fait plaisir petit
gaming entre poteau même si on n'est
plus potable 7 nuls quoi [ __ ] tu
casses toi ta phut à quoi ça mange pas
fait exprès j'étais vraiment poussé
[Musique]